hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about clogged arteries or
a thorough score on ik plucking there's
confusion in that area in that most
people focus on the cholesterol they
want to lower the cholesterol to avoid
clogged arteries and they want to do it
by eliminating butter fat eggs animal
meat okay but what I want to bring up is
some additional data that has to do with
the chain reaction that occurs before
the cholesterol even comes in there in
the chamber beds the first thing that
happens is you get this thing called a
lesion or an inflammatory State in the
lining of the muscle in the artery okay
so it's a little tiny muscle muscular
layer that you get this inflammation now
in a vein you don't get clogged arteries
because you don't have those muscle
contractions veins are a bit more
passive they don't have that contractile
muscle tissue so you don't have this
situation it's only in arteries so you
have this first thing that occurs with
inflammation now what comes next is the
cholesterol but cholesterol the purpose
of this cholesterol is to help heal that
inflammation it acts as a band-aid
that's what it's there for I don't know
if you knew this but your body makes
2,000 milligrams of potassium every
single day every cell wall is made from
cholesterol all your hormones
specifically sex hormones and other ones
are made from cholesterol or your body
makes a lot of it one egg yolk is only I
guess it's 300 milligrams your body
makes 3,000 if your body makes so much
why is it bad so the point is it's
trying to heal this inflammation okay
because you also get calcium formation
on the same plaquing so you have this
cement that goes in there to try to heal
it as well and so we got a combination
of calcium plaque cholesterol plaquing
and fibrin plaquing what's fibrin
vibrant is a kind of like a connected
collagen tissue
a fibrous tissue to help seal off that
wound just like any scar would be so
we're getting scarring on the inside of
our artery with these three things right
here there's some other things that
accumulate too like the polysaccharides
I'm not going to get into that it's a
little too confusing but the point is
that we must understand the first thing
that happen is the inflammation and then
these things happen secondarily so if
we're going to come in late on a chain
and start dropping calcium and fiber and
cholesterol did we really fix anything
well people say well I went on a
plant-based diet and I healed my body
well that's because you healed
inflammation and your cholesterol is
going to come down because there's no
longer needed to heal this let's talk
about what causes inflammation stress
that's that cortisol very destructive on
the body stressful foods junk foods of
course and an insulin that's all the
refined grains breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits sugar all that stuff
our body an average American consumes
149 pounds of sugar every single year so
that's a lot of insulin of course that's
going to create inflammation in your
arteries the desserts the alcohol that
will do it as well
and also not having enough omega-3 fatty
acids it's like fish oils things like
that or flax oil so there's a lot of
things here that can cause it smoking
can cause that other chemicals in your
body but the point is that the real
cause of a clogged artery is bad habits
creating inflammation and then all these
are just the things that it's kind of
like the icing on the cake it's the
thing that comes later so now that you
understand this then we can actually get
rid of these things and then watch this
go down because I'll have people tell me
I went in a plant-based diet a
vegetarian diet and I got rid of my
cholesterol my clogged arteries well I
also have other people that went in a
meat diet and got rid of their the what
the cluster went down to why because
they stopped having the carbohydrates
the refined carbohydrates the insulin so
that's some deeper data on the clogged
artery mechanism I'll see in the next
video